this is a production of cornell
university
hello my name is carl scamenti from the
cornell turf grass program
and today i'm going to talk about a
brief case study on a project we're
working on
called the environmental results program
that aims to increase adoption of best
management practices
on golf courses in new york
and so part of this project is to
implement bmps
that will protect water quality
at actual facilities in our region
and so today's uh bmp is going to be at
pearl lakes golf course
uh which is a nine-hole golf facility up
in skinny atlas new york
uh it's a kind of a par-3 short course
so very accessible community-based um
very affordable for the for the people
in our region
and what we did up there is some basic
soil chemical testing
um so the idea behind soil testing on
golf courses is to
first of all establish baseline soil
nutrient levels uh but then to use that
data to build an efficient fertilizer
program
and when we say efficient we mean
applying only the nutrients that are
necessary for
turfgrass health and not excess
when you apply excess nutrients and
fertilizer
um you're not only wasting money but
you're increasing the risk of runoff and
leaching of those nutrients that can get
into water bodies and cause issues
um
so just some basics on what we did out
of pearl lakes
what did we use to soil sample
just a basic soil probe a container to
put our samples in
ziploc bags that's what you put your
samples in to send them off to the lab
lab with a sharpie
and then just some sand to back fill the
holes and smooth everything over once
we're done
and then some more fundamentals
if you're new to soil testing
how many greens do you want to do if you
have 18 greens at your facility
you may only want to do a couple so
choosing a representative sample
for your golf course that means a couple
of your best greens couple your worst
greens
and a couple in between
we'll give you a good sample
if you can't do every green at your golf
course
about eight to ten samples per surface
uh depends on the size of the green and
uh but make sure you're you're spacing
those out evenly across the the green
again representative sample there
and consistent sampling depth so
you'll notice um on our soil sampling
device here we've got a little piece of
duct tape that just makes sure that
every time we sample we're getting the
same depth for consistency's sake
again consistency
if you're going to do this annually
taking samples the same time of year
and using the same lab every single time
it's going to ensure that consistency
year over year
all right so the results you'll send
your samples in and you will get
something like this
a lot of numbers flying around here what
do they mean
uh what is a good number what is a bad
number
that's where you need an interpretation
method
and the one we recommend is the minimum
levels of sustainable nutrition
so that is mlsn for short and this is a
very simple way of interpreting soil
test results
all you need is enough right so the mlsn
levels are based on
thousands of of turf grass samples
across the world
and each number here is just the
concentration in the soil that is the
minimum level that will maintain healthy
turf
so if we're looking at potassium 37
parts per million is that minimum level
if we get a soil test back that says 50
parts per million
great we're good to go we are above that
37 number the turf has all it needs
now if we had 100 right it's it's it's
really no different according to mlsn we
still have enough we are still above
that minimum level
there's no optimum just being above that
is the important thing here
um so the only time you need fertilizer
for any of these elements is if you are
below the minimum level right so if we
have 20 parts per million
okay then we have to go in
and we can apply some potassium to get
us above that mlsn
um so looking at the results from pearl
lakes we can see
pretty obviously this phosphorus column
is is the one highlighted in red
every green is below the mlsn level for
phosphorus um
this tracks with some uh historical
observations where seeding wasn't super
successful
on some of the putting greens um
so looking at this data we'd say
phosphorus is below the ml sun level we
need to go in and apply some fertilizer
so that the turf grass has what it needs
to be healthy
now how much fertilizer we apply that's
a little bit more a detailed discussion
we have a case study link below that
goes through the calculations you'll
need
to figure out exactly how much
phosphorus
um but what we're going to do here is
just talk about what the recommendations
for mlsn were
versus what conventional more
traditional recommendations would be
so right here we have
the mlsn interpretation versus
slan which again is more conventional
method
um if we're looking at just phosphorus
here on the left uh mlsn recommended
about a pound per thousand
of phosphorus fertilizer
slain recommended more than twice that
right so we're looking across the whole
golf course 40 pounds to about 100
pounds
and we see even a more exaggerated
example looking at potassium
mlsn recommended zero right and slan
recommended almost 200 pounds across the
entire golf course
four and a half pounds per thousand
um this is pretty common any
interpretation method other than mlsn is
going to recommend more fertilizer
and if you're wondering well does that
mean the grass is going to look better
um what we're finding is there's
research research showing now that mlsn
is providing the same turf turf grass
quality the same results
with much less fertilizer
and that's kind of the point
looking at mlsn as an interpretation
method
you're going to get the same turfgrass
quality with less fertilizer and for you
that means
less money spent
and also it means a reduced risk of
possibly contaminating your water your
water bodies around the golf course
property
with excess nutrients
so thanks for listening to this case
study at pearl lakes golf course
uh again we'll have our case study link
below that goes a little bit more in
detail about
how you use um the mls send to calculate
fertilizer requirements
uh we've hoped you learned something and
look forward to seeing you soon this has
been a production of cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu